some of you on the comments on the
previous video of mentioned computer
systems some experimental ones that were
once built working on a base three
basics Roman base two sometimes a base
three number either 0 1 or 2 following
on from bits is called tricks because
the base 3 system some textbooks call it
trinary some textbooks call it ternary
but it's the same thing it's a base 3
system now here's the magic thing with
these things being exact negative powers
of 3 I can confidently predict that if
only we could calculate entropy in
traits and codings traits we could
probably get a more efficient coding
let's have a look we can do this
probably quite quickly now but if you're
doing it base 3 the rule now is you
combine the three rightmost
probabilities all in one go and the 3
right most things are 1/9 19.9 so I'm
getting here a trinary or ternary tree
not a binary one 190 190 1/9 combine
them all into one third till to those
and then if you're combining in threes
well you put a third a third a third
easy good good good probably see one
point no good now here's a clever thing
what you now do in labeling your
branches of course is if you go left
label at 0 we go down the middle
label it 1 if you go to the right label
it too and then as you recursively
descend down this you're on a 2 now if
you then go to the left you append to 0
if you then go down the middle you
append a 1 and if you then go to the
right again
you end up with 2 those are codes that
have been worked out in tricks I can
then tell you this 0 is for COD they
code one is for they
catch a bass tuna shark and Barracuda
effectively in sequence become 2 0 2 1
and 2 2 in trick codings I have now
calculated my entropy as being the sum
over these five states minus P I log to
the base 3 of P I I worked out he lost
the base 3 so the answer comes out in
tricks and it's one point three three
trips my average length is the sum from
1 to 5 of the length of code associated
with the given catch or state times the
probability of that catch so you're
getting things like you know a one trick
code times the third plus a one trick
code tons another third add them all
together amazing it comes to one point
three three trips because of the nature
of these probabilities they map into
being whole numbers of tricks needed the
probably doing of this bits was that
they don't map exactly onto logs the
base 2 is clean whole numbers so you end
up having to waste a bit and round up as
it were
whereas Tritt hits it right on the nail
look at this efficiency is 1.33 over one
point three three hits 100% however the
word of warning I think I ought to say
is someone says hey look that's
fantastic you've got one point three
three traits of entropy you've got two
point 1 1 3 bits of entropy over the
same thing why not use traits all the
time
you've lowered the entropy no I haven't
it's just using different units and the
way to think of this is something like
the following the amount of information
is constant that you can measure it in
different
units it's a bit like having a 1
kilogram bag of sugar the one kilogram
bag of sugar is an amount of sugar if I
choose to I could revert back to
imperial units and say it's actually 2.2
pounds and of course those of you in
North America still use the imperial
system we'll say hey I'd like that in
pounds and ounces so yes it's 2/10 of 16
ounces which is 3.2 and yeah so it's 2
pounds and 3.2 ounces so if you want it
totally in ounces to 16 to 32 it's 35
point two ounces worth of sugar but it's
still the same amount of sugar that
doesn't change at all same thing here
1.3 three tricks of information is the
same amount as 2.11 three bits so you're
not winning out in BT entropy but where
you are winning out here is being able
to get your average code length down
that might matter to you quite a lot
saying oh if only I'm allowed to use
digits like zero one and two
I can send fewer of them than if I have
to be limited to zeros and ones